Hodgman est mon rédempteur empoisonne un pro et
je suis Frankie the Medina new versus
solidify my auntie para por show me
Nikki la plus chère la plus douce un donateur qui à
l'
activité de New York pour savoir si c'est le
numéro de Patrick Warminster puisque c'est pourquoi
la satisfaction commune d'Eva se sent qui a gardé  leur
supposons que la New York garde Guzman
Pshonka par mr.  Malpani Oscar party
Katmandu Paula Segundo joue et fait un
mohawk infinitif Giacomo dit que Tony a dit que la
vidéo dica montre les résultats
ne pas tactiquer sur calibrer l'
effet sur du tout bien allez
sim finalement le thé est prêt échantillon
Merci camarade Kelly blonde grasse vous pouvez prendre
bienvenue à Voyager 2 si vous en apprenez plus
votre sauce Sampat aqua
venez à l'arrière l'un de vous un plus
bilatéral  Je suis coincé à Katmandou tu sais que tu me
manques
Exeter cebiche une nouvelle interdiction d'abus d'aide
ça te dit quelque chose et je suis l'
Empire turc sauf si peu comme tout le monde par
naturellement fuku le menu du moment passé
plus mais que je suis une chanson puante
proposée sur garage à  en cours pour tester
en couverture et mettre mon CV berapa
s'il devient liberté bouge plus
Boosh ok viens pal Eric vois diamant
Exodus toi moi aussi je suis un accident comme la ville
devient une constante ok salut salut
disapper mo  ve it Sakana logic dessiner un
legit II savoir cos Omegan T ou de la
responsabilité de Yadier à une
instruction préférée tonale est EDT trans-lux une
sortie de salvia de Vibha Swanepoel ardente la
sécurisation de notre pouvoir regarde sur Tom quelques
papiers sur tous les câbles dans l'ambassade
merci  vous beaucoup par le code promo
pour faire consommer tout setúbal parte de moi
tout le monde Amina et faites-vous une voie
Anya Kim Alvin jr.  dans la baguette
Université mais stupide mes osselets
enlèvent le délicat parce que détends-toi
je vais pêcher Lester pue cb-cid
ouais ouais si tu veux dire bonjour à mes
abonnés
ce sont j'adore ce violon c'est
nouveau tous ces trucs d'éclairage maintenant  Bon
appétit mmm d'accord Ally il y a euh il
y a quelque chose que je voulais te montrer d'accord
prêt essaie de deviner ce qui peut être
tu n'as aucun indice tu
dois parler plus fort c'est quoi je
veux savoir d'accord cette douleur c'est un  capteur
qui vibre à chaque fois que je fais face
au nord ouais
et de cette façon j'ai un nouveau sens tu
sais comme nous avons comme nous voyons nous entendons le
goût et l'odeur
il y a avec la peau il y a le toucher
et j'ai un autre sens que je sais
où est  Nord-Sud ce genre de vraiment
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose qui ne fait pas de mal alors
qu'en pensez-vous
Je pense que c'est fou maintenant j'apprends des
Américains ça vibre quand je fais face
au nord donc le Nord-Est entend ouais je
sachez que c'est derrière nous parce que quand nous
quand je suis assis ici tu sais quand on change de
ville ouais j'ai senti que ça vibrait
ne sois pas l'écran regarde ici
je regardais et criais tout le temps tout
le temps ouais c'est ce que mon visage ça
m'a coûté avec tout
ça m'a coûté 500 euros oh  vraiment ouais donc
c'est comme si c'était comme 50 000 roupies ouais
c'est beaucoup c'est cher ouais c'est une
expérience coûteuse c'est comme un portefeuille
comme euh ça pompe tout comme je ne pense pas que
tu ne le pensais pas mais je ne peux pas être
sûr à 100% parce que tu  jamais sûr de quoi que ce soit
ouais mais d'après ce que j'ai lu et d'après l'
étude que j'ai faite j'ai fait je n'ai pas trouvé
de sueur je veux dire incroyable il y a
rien de jamais entendu vraiment je n'ai jamais
vu j'ai vu comme compiz est et  ouest
tu sais c'est quoi ce high board ouais
oui moi ouais entre les humains et les robots
j'adore expérimenter des trucs
je n'ai jamais je suis choqué maintenant c'est
très étonnant je suis content d'avoir pu te le montrer
allié c'était un plaisir ouais moi  trop
pareil ici si tu vas à Katmandou vas à
la boutique d'Ally tu vas t'envoyer  quelques
bijoux merci où est la bienvenue tu
vas me donner l'adresse des
magasins vont se positionner
Merci bienvenue mon frère je l'apprécie
moi aussi
c'est le conducteur genévrier je suis joystick
kuduro dehors moi chez toi Johnny me
donnera des positifs me montre  ouais épisode
faux j'ai écrit
lk0 comme votre légume je n'ai pas de chapitre
sur le projet de plante de sel et de poivre inventé
était un respect adaptatif développé utilisez-le
pour sécuriser le craqueur de stock ou le zoo de Kobe
a Popeye
[Musique]
vous connaissez la musique c'est  a ça s'appelle
dormir dans un bleu tu sais ça ici c'est
bleu
[Musique]